[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN TINGLEY: How can you
be ready for what's ahead?
Data science has gone
from hype to reality.
What was once the realm of
scientists and engineers
has become central to health care,
government, finance, advertising, even
education.
If you're a leader or a
decision maker, or you're just
looking to make sense of data
science, this is your place to start.
It's not a programming course.
Instead, it's meant
to give you the tools
you need for a world that will never
stop giving you more information.
Featuring real world case studies
and interviews with industry experts.
Digging deep into examples from
health care privacy and more.
We'll show you what worked.
KADE CROCKFORD: Hey.
I saw what you guys
did in San Francisco.
Let's do it in Somerville too.
ED DAVIS: Inequities in the
health and criminal justice
system, police brutality issues, issues
around COVID, these are all problems
that big data can affect.
DUSTIN TINGLEY: We'll
show you what didn't work.
CRAIG A. UMSCHEID: Unfortunately,
I think as an institution,
we got out ahead of ourselves.
LATANYA SWEENEY: If
somebody takes a data set
that's supposed to be anonymous and
they re-identify the people in it,
all kinds of harms can happen.
KADE CROCKFORD: This technology
was not just science fiction.
It was becoming science reality.
DUSTIN TINGLEY: And you'll find out why.
The information is at your fingertips.
Are you data science ready?
[MUSIC PLAYING]